justin bieber is not happy with what the
top
image results are on google when you
search his name
we'll let him explain i'm just gonna
talk to
uh some i guess i guess google
i don't know what the algorithm is for
why
certain photos come up but um
this is so frustrating um
considering i took a lot of time to get
healthy
and um i feel as though like
people try to legitimately sabotage me
now watch i'm gonna go to images
i i mean
this was a time where i was really
unhealthy i was battling lyme disease
right
all of the top photos are me
looking disheveled right like
i was obviously going through a tough
time but it's like
these are the photos that the media
tries to run with i don't know if
they do it because they try to there's
so many new
photos that have service to the media
and they continue to use these photos so
it's like what
what's the deal i don't know it's
frustrating me i wish they would change
it i've asked them to change it
um i've done a lot of photo shoots since
then
and um yeah they could just
you know they don't have to put these
photos but they do and i'm i just
i don't know why i mean look at my skin
now there's so many photos they could
choose
the funny thing is i know he's saying
like he was going through a bad time
i think he looks fine in those photos he
looks pretty good in those photos
a lot of people didn't know he was going
through a bad time at that time right so
i mean
there's one thing that's him looking at
it obviously is like
brings back a bad time to him brings
back bad memories we didn't know about
it
for a while so i guess there's that but
i
i mean it must be frustrating if you
look you know
look up yourself on google and the first
picture you see is a picture you hate
right right like that must be right that
can't be fun
right favorite thoughts
it's a tough one i mean i don't even
know who who decides what pops up i i
guess it's google yeah
whatever you need what the algorithms
are yeah
yeah i mean it just is what it is i mean
i don't really i'm not really sure what
i think about that i i've actually i
haven't googled myself in a really long
time so i have no idea
what uh what pictures are up on me so
well they're not too bad
well i'm going to help you out right now
tb because i googled you and looked at
the images
so let's go no yours are fine so looks
so that's that's the top results for you
and if you can see them yeah they're
pretty good like i don't think what do
you think of those photos they're great
those look good to me that's not bad
yeah i think those look pretty good i
mean
there's no like bad photo there you look
good
so yeah let's break it down looking at
looking at that sheet table like
yeah what's the best way to be happy
with people seeing that like oh i want
i want them to see those images with me
that's cool right
yeah i mean i'll i'll i'll take those
yeah those are good
so then i i googled myself uh mine are
pretty good
there's actually a couple photos that i
don't um remember at all
so the one it's kind of a really mixed
uh bag in there
yeah yeah you're in there google your
picture it's you and me together yeah
that's nice
the funny thing is the bottom left one
where i'm with those two kids
i'm clearly doing a piece for city line
i used to work for that show that's
probably about nine or ten years ago
i don't remember that at all i don't
remember those kids
i think it was like a back to school
thing but i don't remember
anything about that photo so that's that
now oh yeah so then
the one with the you see the one in the
middle with the creepy guy
linking the reporter that's not me the
only thing i can think is i think we did
a story on that
on live so maybe that's why i'm linked
to that photo but yeah that's not me
and that's not me with the glasses
either so i don't understand that one
but the best one
sorry we did that story on live i
remember that sorry so i think that's
why that's going to be heartbroken when
they hear that you don't well they're
like
but they would be like 20 now because
that's like 10 years ago um but then the
best one
is carlos carlos she has some
competition when you google
carlos bustamante so take a look at this
so so there's uh
there's a yeah he's like a college
professor
it's mostly you yeah there's a couple in
there that's there's this college
professor
he's got a phd carlos so you have some
competition there
um elsa listen
if you're if your life is a is an art
he's winning
a hundred percent true i like your long
hair my goal
photo oh thank you my goal actually over
the last few years i remember googling
my own name
years ago and being like who is this man
who who is that man i need to get in the
top search results for my own name so at
least i'm there and did you see it like
that's a thumbnail did you see the other
one at the very bottom i didn't actually
click on it yeah it's like
a very old man see that one that's like
a painting that's carlos
i can't read it from carlos maria
something bustamante see that one that's
like a
aristocrat what's that see that one see
maybe that's like your great great great
grandfather yeah you're probably really
true
i know i know that i need that jacket
that's what i know we got darling shawn
mendes in there too yeah it's a good mix